the joe rogan experience but you know
there's been
comic like ricky gervais is a great
example that they've done very well
he's got a great show on netflix he's
great at everything he's great
he's fiery funny funny yeah and i i
loved when he was hosting the golden
globes
it was great really great yeah i mean he
just tells him shut the [ __ ] up
yeah because there's so much virtue this
latest thing where all these actors have
this black and white
video where they're talking about racism
i take responsibility for that
what are you doing you know what i was
saying to my friend i go you know what
that is these [ __ ] haven't
gotten any attention
exactly for months because they haven't
been filmed
jumping on it well you talked about it
with the the song imagine
at the beginning right yes you [ __ ]
more they got
the blow back from that well they could
blow back from this too
everything they try to do that virtue
signals like you know
we're going to take a stand this is no
longer going to happen it's
not good like nobody thought it was good
like this is not what this is what this
is is a [ __ ] horrible cop
it's a really bad guy who killed
somebody it's not like these actors are
out there
being racist and holding people back and
trying that's not what you're doing like
what are you
you're taking responsibility no you're
trying to get attention that's what
you're doing
this stupid [ __ ] thing you're doing i
wish that
if they ever feel like doing that again
call me
call me i'll tell you how it's gonna
turn out every one of these dumb things
you're going to do i'll tell you how
it's going to come out
if you're going to have one actor and
then the next you're going to cut to
each one of them
i take responsibility no you do you take
attention
you're sucking it up like a sponge shut
the [ __ ] up and wait you're a week away
from filming again
but that that's also we've talked about
there's people that do stuff
you know for the money right and then
there's some that
the money's irrelevant they need to be
told how great they are and pat
on the back that's what they need and
then there's some of them that are so
wrapped up in this liberal and
progressive ideology that they literally
can't see how dumb this looks to the
rest of the world
they think they're going to do a good
thing and they think that through their
celebrity they're going to use their
platform
and their voice and they're going to
make a difference if you really think
that as a professional actor you're
going to make a [ __ ] difference
with racism and crime and violence and
police brutality
you should stop acting because you
should go to a [ __ ] doctor and get
your head checked i agree there's
something
wrong with that just shut up and act
shut up and act like if you've got
opinions on this you can express your
opinions yeah
yeah and people you know but don't
preach
but that that video was a little bit
crazy sanctimonious and very you know
yeah i got it from a bunch i don't even
know what it means i'll be honest with
you it means i want attention
yeah it means i want attention and get
ready to cringe get ready to clinch your
butthole shut and go oh
no no what are you doing what are you
doing that was
that was kind of weird do you guys know
who kyle dunnigan is no
kyle dynasty i know he's a comic right
yeah hilarious comic who does a lot of
these face swap videos
and uh he he he does caitlyn jenner
like [ __ ] it's one of the his
instagram page is the funniest
[ __ ] instagram page on the planet
earth by far
but he's got this new one that he did
where he go do it jamie
go to kyle dunigan's instagram page you
guys see this where he has
these characters that he does with the
face swap and he
shoves them into that video
so you get and it's just that i couldn't
yeah wait wait do you see this because
this is the perfect antidote for that
cringe
here we go jamie uh we'll cue this up
here
jamie the guy is a goddamn genius i take
responsibility i don't see it jamie
did you see this steve taylor
responsibility
i'm on the fence about it
i take responsibility for every
unchecked moment for every time i said
give me
five on the left-hand side
i'll take responsibility for not
listening to megan
and leaving me knickers on the floor
they're called underpants i will no
longer allow an unchecked moment
i will no longer throw away the
african-american part of the oreo cookie
just to get to the creamy white mill
i will hire more black hookers going for
a job should not be a death sentence
sleeping
in your own home should not be a death
sentence uh
sorry i guess i don't know
we are no longer bystanders well who the
hell's that broad
racist murderous cops need
need blind the only time is gonna stop
was when you start
truly holding the perpetrators uh
uh to account start putting them in jail
you're welcome
that's good that's good but that's
nothing compared to some of his other
[ __ ] yeah
go to his page if you need someone to
laugh at but have you seen the real one
yeah you saw it he does ones with the
kardashians where he has
caitlyn jenner talking to the
kardashians but the kardashians don't
really talk they just make noises
like me me me bibi no you're [ __ ]
idiot that's not what i said
like it's it's
it's it's genius it's genius
yeah this is what it is i mean everybody
and i like a lot of those people that
are in that video unfortunately i think
they're great
i just think somebody should talk to
them somebody outside the business
just grab them by the shoulder publicist
they're not seeing people they're
not getting feedback that's what it is
yeah they need feedback
someone needs to grab and go listen to
me don't don't do this
don't do this don't do this
[Applause]